Carnegie Mellon has a very distinguished
history in brain racing starting in the
late 1950s we had some of the most
prominent people in the world that were
starting the field of computer science
and thinking about what we think of now
as artificial intelligence and so this
really set the stage that became all the
things we think of as modern brain
research through the rest of the century
and present-day
the type of research going on here
really builds upon the long tradition
that Carnegie Mellon has in technology
and computation Carnegie Mellon
University has put together a brand new
initiative which we call brain hub to
address the large challenges that are
associated with understanding both the
basic science associated with brain
function but also the relationship
between brain function and various kinds
of diseases including autism Alzheimer's
disease and Parkinson's disease brain
hub is an initiative that brings
together people across campus from
disciplines as diverse as engineering
and statistics to biology and psychology
and it's this multidisciplinary effort
that I think it's really going to enable
us to make enormous progress in this
area my own personal research has to do
with understanding the human visual
system and I've been interested not in
how the eye works or how the early parts
of the visual system work but really how
you take all that information that's
streaming in constantly from your
everyday experience and turn that into
your experience about object scenes
people faces all the things that we
actually think about and then we
interact with all the time that really
make up our visual world when you open
your eyes and you see the world laid out
in front of you how is it that the brain
has constructed meaning and precision of
the visual world so rapidly from the
course information that it receives from
the research that I do is to try and
understand how this is achieved what is
it that the brain is doing what are the
mechanisms one of the psychological one
of the neural mechanisms that give rise
to this meaningful coherent unified
perception with such rapidity my current
research involves investigating cellular
ensembles that are engaged by sensory
experience and we're particularly
interested in somatic sensation because
there's a very clear map for how sensory
input drive cells in the in the cerebral
cortex so there might be 20 different
neuron types in the cerebral cortex we'd
like to be able to genetically label
each one of those and see develop a
complete matrix for how individual types
of cells are talking to each other in
order to do this we're using machine
learning tools we're using molecular
genetic techniques and we're working
with imaging and statistical resources
here at the University
what we're doing in my research group is
to try to understand how large
populations of neurons work together
using novel statistical machine learning
methods and particular questions that
were very interested in right now
involve learning and one of the tools
that we're using to study learning is
brain computer interfaces hopefully this
knowledge will allow us to develop
systems to help people learn better both
for rehabilitation as well as you know
for learning as we grow an age brain hub
is breaking onto the world stage in a
number of ways including through formal
affiliations with a host of
international partners and a number of
local partners including the University
of Pittsburgh with whom we've had a very
long association there are over a
hundred twenty faculty members who are
involved in some sort of brain research
here at Pittsburg and everyone is within
10 minutes of walking distance from each
other and this creates a really vibrant
community and I believe that this is one
of the fastest growing and most exciting
places to do brain research today
Carnegie Mellon is very serious about
pursuing cutting-edge brain research and
cutting-edge science in general and in
particular taking the really special
things about Carnegie Mellon
particularly our engineering and our
computer science and bringing them into
how we study one of the most complex
things with no one universally human
brain there is tremendous urgency for us
right now to use these different methods
to use our expertise to understand the
brain and its alteration so that we can
really begin to address these diseases
that we see in humans and bring about
some kind of change for the
you